so you and your brother now have both
experienced huge success with Blum house
so I am kind of curious did Edwin give
you any advice based on his experience
making the purge before jumping into
this yeah you know he gave me advisory
he told me about you know highlights
experience was that you know I thought
things were gonna go smooth there's
gonna be good experience it was you know
it was awesome now the I guess the only
thing we gotta get is both of us on
screen at Santana never happened it has
but it's been a while I mean you're in
dog with a vengeance to go together you
know a few little shows here and there
but you know we're itching to do a film
together and you know right now both of
our careers are good you know he's doing
this thing I'm doing mine but you know
get back to it to get on the main stage
I'd like to see that now just because
I'm curious is there anything in
particular you guys would want to do
together like a certain type of role of
genre anything yeah so my brother is
writing I think yes two films right now
that he's written that he's trying to
get sold and produced that he has in
mind for both of us I'm developing two
films right now with my brother not to
star so you know if it's no one come to
no opportunities who will come to us oh
wow so if you're if you're doing some
work behind the lens right now I am
curious what is your biggest takeaway
working on a film that operates with
this exceptional Blum house model of you
know low budget high production value
that you're gonna take on to your own
films uh you know with a lower budget I
found that people tend to be a bit more
you know I I mean no no offense anybody
but when it comes to working with the
lower budget on such a high profile film
you get people that just show up because
you can't waste time you can't waste
money and you think about the budget we
had for this film you think about the
production quality that we actually got
most people would not believe what the
budget actually was hear that but that's
when you get people who know exactly
what they want do exactly what they want
to do it's not like we can oh no oh and
let's let's just get another 10 mil to
go fix this not like you got people that
show up and they are on top third a game
every single step of the way and that's
what I really love about our entire crew
with this film and everybody was on top
so you learned how to get the most out
of out of out of lenient resources and
it teaches you how to manage things you
know and this was definitely a fantastic
education in doing that I'll challenge
you to get even more creative and
sometimes a whole lot of happy magic
comes out of it well that is the thing
you have to maintain being creative
along the entire way you know a lot of
stunts that we did and and and special
effects that we had a lot of it was
practical you know we didn't have a
green screen for a lot of these things
so a lot of what's practical you see our
stunt team and our effects team coming
up with these really fantastic sort of
of ideas and then you're like oh you
know if we could rely on you know a big
you know fancy the CGI and all this and
green-screen for everything you know you
probably wouldn't have had that
innovative idea pop up you know so we
did use you know some green screen CGI
for some banks you know of course
visibility and all that but you still
see so much more innovation that a sort
of pours out of people because the
resource is now different you know your
resource is all you know back here and
what can make mix with your hands see
you know pays off well in this one I'm
so excited I get to talk to you when the
the blue race coming out because I do
want to ask you some spoiler questions
in particular I want to know about the
relation
between James and Cecilia and how much
that evolved from when you first started
working on the project and what we see
in the final film because I don't know
it was just so nice to see such a
powerful friendship and have it stay
entirely in the friendship box I love
that yeah honestly that was the
conversation that was probably the
primary conversation when it came to the
two to not have it leak over into this
idea of possible romance it is it would
have seemed weird we may have taken the
value or out of the context of what
their real relationship was you know we
wanted to make sure that people
understood there it was a real true
earnest friendship there plus you know
she's going through this tough time I
had and she's staying at James's place
it would be sort of awkward to you know
like she'll chef yeah I mean let's pray
because she needs to feel safe in the
thing I love about the representation of
that is that we can show because his
relationships are real you know we can
show that you know woman especially in
times of parallel there is a safe thing
that she can feel there are stand-up
guys who are out there who are going to
be the protector and you learn to
respect and in honor you know that woman
stayed at Bing and plus he has a little
daughter you know he has to be a good
role model fire so in terms of their
friendship you know it kicks back all
the way to childhood at this point it's
like basically family but we wanted to
just continue to honor what that was so
even if you don't tell all the history
we show it and how they treat each other
going through this this journey together
hands down one of my favorite components
of the movie I do want to ask you about
that very last conversation you two have
together though and in particular what
do you think James does after the movie
ends because I think he clearly knows
what's up what happened in there but
he's also a cop so after the fact you
think he wrestles with the truth of what
really happened uh you know I don't know
there's a sequel we might be able to
find out that
but I think James made his decision in
that monk you know he knows who the
peril that she's been through and I
think that at that point he understands
she had to do what she had to do
whatever that was I might even say four
people but he decides the more valuable
thing the more valuable choice is to be
her friend and not to be mr. cop you
know at the moment he said look just I
get it you know and and I might he might
have you know not called some things in
he might not have uh you know reported a
few things changed um he earns the right
to be in that headspace at the end of
the movie so it's totally backed up
besides he got his butt whooped like
come on now that's probably in the back
of his mind thinking oh